Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch zeigen.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Das war's für heute.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels hier ist der Max und ich hab ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine Ahnung
wirklich nicht den blassesten Schimmer wo dieses Video jetzt auftaucht und wann dieses
Video auftaucht ich nehme das ganze jetzt hier auf weil ich ein neues Feature testen will auf
Twitch denn Twitch hat heute die neuen Video Producertools angekündigt das heißt man kann
jetzt in seinem Twitch Video Manager Videos hochladen also quasi Sachen nicht Livestream
Sachen die man vorher aufgenommen hat also sprich das Video ist nicht live das habe ich vorher
aufgenommen und man kann jetzt quasi irgendwie eine ein primären Datum ansetzen und dann werden
wohl alle die Following informiert oder sowas in der Richtung ihr müsst mir jetzt mal schreiben
oder sagen oder wie immer das funktioniert kein Schimmer wie das jetzt für euch aussieht ich
weiß es nicht ehrlich gesagt ich probiere es jetzt auch gerade zum ersten mal aus und dann kann
man sich das wohl zusammen bei dieser Premiere dann mit seiner Community angucken und im Live
Chat sinnlose Twitch Memes rumspammen oder was man eben so machen will und ich finde das lustig
dass das Timing gerade jetzt von Twitch kommt beziehungsweise von Amazon ich meine es ist ja
Amazon mittlerweile und gerade jetzt wo YouTube sagt dass kleinere Channels wahrscheinlich aus
dem YouTube Partner Programm fliegen also sprich die nicht genug Abos haben beziehungsweise genug
Viewtime haben aus dem Abo Programm fliegen gerade jetzt sagt Twitch wir bieten quasi eine
Alternative zu YouTube und die Frage ist ist das hier eine Alternative zu YouTube das muss ich
jetzt mal zeigen es gibt ja ein paar Sachen die zurzeit im Trend sind so als Alternative von YouTube
zu wie hieß dieses wie hieß dieses diese Plattform die letzten so als ultra YouTube neues YouTube
gehyped wurde mit mir mit mir ist ja mittlerweile wer es noch nicht mitgekriegt hat mit mir war ja
vor ein paar Monaten so voll im Hype jeder hat sich in mit mir Channel gemacht ich übrigens nicht
und mittlerweile wer heute auf mit mir geht wird feststellen goodbye for now with me has moved also
sprich mit mir ist mittlerweile dicht aber es gibt so ein paar neue Sachen jetzt das eine hier auf
Twitch dann gibt es die Tube also quasi in den Video Portal mit eigener so wie ich das verstanden
habe mit eigener Kryptowährung hinten dran wo man dann ausbezahlt wird irgendwie über den Einfluss
den seine Videos haben keine muss ich mir auch mal irgendwann angucken in Zukunft aber jetzt ist das
halt hier von Twitch so der Versuch ein bisschen YouTube Konkurrenz zu machen und ganz ehrlich ich
begrüße das wenn es mehr Seiten gibt die es habe ich auch letztens hier in dem Streamer irgendwann
erzählt ich finde es gut wenn es Seiten gibt die YouTube Konkurrenz machen denn das da profitieren
denke ich letztendlich alle davon es gibt ganz wenige Leute von denen ich die jetzt schon länger bei
YouTube dabei sind die auch ein bisschen mal was mit YouTube zu tun hat ein bisschen Probleme hatten
vielleicht auch Probleme mit ihrem YouTube Netzwerk hatten es gibt ganz wenige Leute die ich kenne
die sagen ich sie finden das toll also die meisten Leute auf YouTube dienen die nervt's an vielen
Stellen auch und ich könnte mir vorstellen dass vor allem Twitch eben da schon ein gewisses
Potenzial hat und es ist auf jeden Fall gut für Zuschauer als auch Content Producer Content Creator
dass es Alternativen gibt und ich glaube Twitch das beste was Twitch machen kann oder das beste
was generell eine Seite machen kann die YouTube Konkurrenz machen möchte und es kam ja letztens
auch erst diese News dass quasi Amazon YouTube Konkurrenz machen will und sowas in der Richtung
vielleicht ist das hier der erste Schritt davon wir wissen es nicht ich finde das aber insofern
gut dass man YouTube Konkurrenz macht beziehungsweise diese Seite die YouTube Konkurrenz macht das beste
was die meiner Ansicht nach machen können ist gar nicht versuchen YouTube irgendwie die die großen
Content Creator abzugraben also sprich nicht so wie das wie das Hitbox und Azubu und sonstige
Seiten gemacht haben sondern indem man einfach neue Leute fördert oder eben Leute die Interesse
an dieser Plattform haben und hier was machen wollen dass man die fördert und dass man sich eben
seine eigenen Content Creator schafft die gute wie die gute Videos machen die für diese Plattform
hier passen sind so jetzt habe ich ganz ganz viel drum gelabert wie geht's eigentlich ich will das
ganze Jahr ausprobieren das ist der ganze das ist der ganze Sinn und Zweck von von diesem Video ich
weiß gar nicht soll ich jetzt noch großartig was was könnte ich jetzt noch großartig erzählen
hinten dran ja doch eine Sache fällt mir noch einer wollte ich aber noch wieder darüber machen ich
kann es mal ganz kurz ganz kurz anreißen ich war zum einem nicht das erste mal aber das erste
mal ist richtig und zwar absichtlich gestern bei einem Arzt den ich komplett selbst bezahlt
habe also ohne ohne gesetzliche Krankenkasse oder sonst was ich bin auch nicht privatversichert
oder sowas ich habe komplett selbst bezahlt und das lag daran weil ich habe bei bei meinem Arzt
vorangehoben wo ich sonst immer hingehe und habe gesagt jungs hier müsste man mal gucken ich habe
hier auf dem kopf so ein bisschen ein bisschen was entzündetes oder so wenn man sieht nicht das
hinten am kopf kann es gar nicht richtig gucken und da hat er gemeint so ja fünf monate warten
was wollte ich mich verarschen ich kann auch keine fünf monaten warten bis mir einer auf den kopf
guckt bis dahin ist es entweder weg oder mal es hat meinen kopf zerfressen oder sowas und habe ich
mir gedacht okay scheiß drauf guckst du mal im internet habe ich google geguckt habe einen
hautarzt gefunden in frankfurt direkt um die ecke bei mir und habe ich mich angerufen habe
gesagt also das war eine rein private praxis habe ich angerufen und gesagt hier müsste ich mal
angucken und hier komplett andere welt ja wie passt es ihnen denn am besten ja morgen 12 uhr wunderbar
habe ich mir gedacht da wird immer erzählt so nach dem motto wir müssen aufpassen dass es in
deutschland keine zwei klassenmedizin gibt muss man ganz ehrlich sagen die haben wir doch also
so offensichtlich wie ich das jetzt diesmal gesehen habe war das gar nicht und ich muss auch sagen
ohne scheiß leute die behandlung die war so viel besser als ich das bisher bei anderen ärzten
erlebt habe ich habe manchmal das gefühl wenn ich zu irgendeinem arzt hingehe dann wirst du
da möglichst schnell durchgeschleust quasi drei minuten pro patient bäme bäme ist mein ich kann
es ja auch aus der sicht verstehen dass man das macht da muss wenn du nicht viel pro patient
kriegst musste halt auch gucken dass du ordentlichen durchsatz hast das problem haben sie da halt nicht
und 25 minuten war ich drin so lange war ich glaube ich die letzten zehn jahre nicht war bei
einem arzt drinnen gefühlt und wir haben alles gemacht haben uns auf den kopf angeguckt dann
auch geguckt wie sich mein haar waschmittel zusammensetzt und was auch alles und dass das vielleicht auch
daran liegen könnte dass es so trocken ist und das prinzip die details sind jetzt egal also ich hatte
das gefühl ich würde super behandelt ja und weiß jetzt was sache ist dass es nicht schlimm ist und
alles ist gut und ich bin damit zufrieden und am ende habe ich 60 euro bezahlt klar kann man jetzt
sagen 60 euro aber irgendwo fand ich dann ich muss sagen als ich da rausgekommen habe ich mir
gedacht hey das ist 60 euro ist eigentlich gut die rechnung kommt jetzt noch ja sind waren ganz gut
investiertes geld also das ist einfach ein riesen unterschied gewesen keine wartezeit ja die hat
noch nicht mal ein wartezimmer die hatten sofas wann habt ihr beim doktor schon mal im sofa und es
war nicht in den sofa das wurde das war so das mega chill sofa ja riesen sofa ist fast versunken
drin wann habt ihr beim arzt schon mal im im im leder sofa gewartet ja wann ihr dran gekommen sein
riesen unterschied muss ich wahnsinn hat mich echt positiv überrascht aber gut kostet auch kohle so
jetzt habe ich sogar noch was sinnvolles in dem video erzählen das war schluss an der stelle jetzt
wird mich mal wirklich interessieren so was was wie ist das hier jetzt gewesen ich habe ich bin selbst
gespannt ja also wir sind jetzt wirklich beide das ist beides neuland ja für euch und für mich ich
habe keine ahnung was wie das hier funktioniert oft jetzt wir gucken uns das ganze jetzt zusammen
an wie gesagt ich bin im chat wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt könnt ihr fragen und vielleicht
mache ich nachher noch livestream gucken wir uns das ganze mal an wir sehen uns dann macht
gut bis zum nächsten mal tschüss